unsere Idee die us-zahlen das Thema
mit derselben Frage an dich
wie üblich die Lage
beim momentanen Lage ist
hoffnungslos aber nicht Ernst Nein Liebe
Sarah Latton 1 ganz prima
wer also die Länder Lage momentan
Bernius gut
was macht die Lage bei der prima
dass sich Karl viel freier
und 2
vor mich hin und schreibt
füge meiner Familie Ben und
Cragg glücklich bin zur verfasst
unverschämt so was zu sagen
Schulden aber glücklich
was du nicht immer glücklich
play-off denn was mich jeden Morgen zu
viel zu tun hatte wenn man Stress Herbst
oder
«Wenn man Sachen machen weil ich machen
will oder nicht ganz viele
Stressfaktoren die meisten suchten sich
aus
und trotzdem ist er gewesen
ich bin ein sehr schnell unzufriedener
Mensch jetzt gerade es ist eher so dass
es
das Spiel so läuft wie ich mir das
vorgenommen habe und
0 für Werder
aber schön Dr
denn bei vielen Kollegen spielte er auch
Existenzangst immer eine Rolle
das heißt
ich habe Sex ist denn Zangs zeitlich auf
der Welt bin
Perovic war im
die philosophischen Sinne wie im
materiellen Sinne dass das kenn ich
jetzt schon
als der Besitzer Söhnen das kenn ich
schon
und irgendwie hat es noch immer gereicht
Dr und es reicht auch jetzt irgendwie
immer
ohne dass ich jetzt und wie konkret
sagen muss dass die nicht ab und dann
mache ich ein Programm und in der Show
will ich mit spielen und das will ich
noch schreiben
es ist gerade so ein bisschen im
luftleeren Raum es ist total schön
dass man was arbeitet was man nicht
sofort irgendjemand
verkaufen will oder anbieten will
ich find das einen großen Luxus und die
Mindeststrafe
und den kannst du die auch leisten
um den kleinen nicht wirklich leisten
aber
den Preis nicht mehr einfach
und es gibt noch ein paar Reserven die
wir jetzt einfach aufbrauchen und dann
muss ich wieder aber die Zeit passen
Werther
was ist das was du jetzt machst also was
ich so glücklich macht
mit diesem Unsinn großes Wort
das hat aber es ist eine Tochter auf der
einen Seite einen Job zu tun dass es um
relativ frisch ist Soloprogramm habe
und die Zeit ist immer gut
also wenn man the Program hat und es
wird funktionieren es gefällt den
Leuten das ist
ausreichend gebucht fühlen
mehr Minden Zeitraum um sich das hat
auch Folgen um die Tour läuft
da hat man erstmal sollen
so Loch so Ruf
die Arbeit hat sich gelohnt die Proben
das einspielen
wir sind dass man gute Momente Tests m
oft Sophie von vielen Kollegen und auch
leider von mir
das den stellte Strom wollen was kommt
jetzt
Inman ich hab ne Prämiere gespielt
und hätte jetzt die Möglichkeit zwei
oder drei Jahre mit dem Programm zu
Touren und wir ganz gemütlich
neue Sachen zu belegen aber halt kaum
ist die Turniere gespielt schon am
zweiten Tag was mache ich jetzt muss ja
was kommt ich muss den Leuten was bieten
hat es diesmal das erste mal nicht
das heißt du bist du dich ich finde
Mensing des Programms ist Prozent ab
einfach richtig richtig glücklich damit
sind die Leute mögen ist
und ich habe zum ersten mal nicht diesen
Druck was mache ich jetzt
sondern ich hab mir diese diese frei rum
genommen Spitzenkraft Festivals und es
ist schon extrem toll
Menschen zum lachen zu bringen
zum nachdenken zu bringen auch mal
vielleicht zu zum Weinen zu bringen
Barth zum Fremdschämen zu bringen das
ist einfach großartig das ist einfach
eine uralte auch falsche Kunst und zwar
egal welche auch das vorlesen ist - von
den Kindern kennt
kann man auf der Bühne machen
vorspielen Vorsingen
sich zu verkleiden
es ist einfach zu groß Arctic
als das Mandat Schlue Lohn sollte
oder nur einen Gott um
Brühl gegen was ist Publikum kann nicht
der einzige Gott sein Geld kann ich der
einzige Gott sein Main
Anspruch kann nicht der einzige Gott
sein
Prozent der Sender dem an was verkauften
sollte und das ist aber auch nicht gut
zehnmal lieber
macht man andere Frisur Krieg als
Dritter vor Danilo di Luca verloren so
dass die Linke gar nicht
CIOs anders an während ich mich nicht
besser das kann alles ist
diese sind ganz viele Sachen wieder
einspielen da muss man
Arbeiter man braucht auch ein bisschen
Standing zu sorgen
ich will aber
dies gibt aber keine Leute dies auch gut
wissen
mich immer besser
Promos um die Fähigkeit haben auf den
Zuhörern oder Leute zu finden den man
vertraut Regisseure Kollegen
«Es entwickelt sich im Laufe der Zeit
dass man es erkennen Irak Dambeck
Quantum natürlich Prozent jährliche
wenn so ein Titel und sagte nur es Super
aber zu lang
dann ist das so ein Lob und rochen
anspornte gefälligst zu kürzen das
Kinn und Werder Bremern
Wochen daran geschrieben hat sagt die
besten beliebig Leben habe
und dann dann arbeitet man mit denen
manchmal gegen welche
mal für welche und irgendwann muss man
es finden
und das findet man auch
dann ist es auch toll also es ist ja
nicht so dass man
ich bin es auch nicht jemand erfährt er
scheitert Raso das ist ja ich kenn schon
Kabarettisten die die Pflanzen waren der
Progress ist nur gut wenn die Hälfte
geht
die gibt's auch
Nein das bin ich nicht er sich da schon
zudem die geliebt werden wollen
es gelingt eine hoch
das ist ein Antrieb ist das geliebt
werden
geliebt zu werden
ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist absurd
wickelt es kaum was anderes für mich
nicht in Frage «Ich wollte dass
schon lange
und dass es bestimmt dieses Gebühr
wundert geliebt werden wollen
mit der Gitarre in der Hand
hat man eine Chance bei den Mädels
Prozent
dieses an Maßnahme vielleicht noch ein
bisschen schlauer Dirk erste ihnen ist
das ganze kommt Nummer Art
was uns alte Priester falls das und das
machen lässt van Gaal demonstriert dass
es von allem was
und das ist aber schon auch eine große
Befriedigung
und auch ein großer Luxus
sich künstlerisch betätigen zu dürfen
dann dann auch die was bin ich das
Arthurs ich mein ich darf das
ich habe die Agentur nicht ab
viele Bühnen wo ich spielen darf es
kommen genug Leute das ist ja Wahnsinn
dem bin ich auch was schuldig das weiß
ich auch
Crime des gemeinsamen
das ist schon ganz großartig auch auf
dieses
das ist auch ein Antrieb
Doerig das nicht funktionieren würde
müsste ich was anderes machen
muss ich aber Schwimmen
große Hochachtung vor Lehrern
und Lehrerinnen aber nur ein Schüler
Interessierte studiert Euro
ich bin allen sehr dankbar dass ich das
nicht machen muss und so den Prozess im
Fall solle das auch nicht immer wieder
zu sagen dass die mehr Geld zu verdienen
sollten und das ist
Bildungssystem einen Riesenpot this
Prozent
ich bin aber sehr froh dass ich es nicht
machen mussten
dieses mal sind keine Kinder
doch Liebe Kinder aber ich hasse dieses
System Schule
Rolf Matter auch nicht ein
zum Elternabend meines Sohnes Moses
riecht schon nach macht und
Unterdrückung wilde zum Dienstgebäude
die Show nicht reicht
und um
ich bin da ich ganz froh
sicherlich zu geben
da gebe ich mir schon noch eine ganze
Weile Mühe
dass sich Prozent nicht da was sich da
auf Hold rechnen können dass ich davon
Leben kann meine Familie ernähren kann
dass ich das nicht machen es ist also
ein Fließ
ist auch ein Antrieb bin ich ganz offen
zu halten sollen
diese künstlerische Arbeit ist toll
aber alles andere gelogen was ist wenn
ich mache Herr Prozent
als Kind sehr klischiert aber ich finde
es ist
es ist Künstler da sein
also zu selten dass mit diesen
tradierten Bild übereinstimmt ich Geh
ins Kaffeehaus ich denke suchen
trinke man kann viel aber diese Phasen
gibt es auch
und die sind toll
wie ist deren
das tradierte Bild des Künstlers mit
der Familie zu vereinbaren
klappt das oder ist
es ist schwierig es ist doch nicht so
schwierig wie man denkt
ich habe das große Glück kommen
in einer WG zu wohnen
und das Prozent
prächtig ihnen nur empfehlen der Haut
gehen
mit Frau und Kind und Prozent
Prozent noch einem Kind und noch einer
Frau und noch einem Mann
das ist eigentlich gar nicht um
darf man das nicht auf meinen Lorbeeren
in meinen Oberkampf einflechten weil die
beiden Ladys
Prozent das Malheur beschlossen haben
m lange lange vor sich hin dann aber
doch zu echten Namen Silvesternacht
sollten wir mal Kinder haben irgendwann
dann macht man das gemeinsam
weil Kerle sind die dem Fall Weg sind
was soll mehr
wahr ist und eine gesellschaftliche
Tatsache
das sanierte Kita gezogen und irgendwann
auch als Vierter WG gewohnt ohne Kinder
und jetzt wollen wir alles zum Sechser
Wege geht mit zwei Kindern die gleich
alt sind wie ich schon
pro sehr lang
wir wohnen seit
ich werde
Leon zu sein
Rolf Bürkl
das klappt und dass es Obama einfach wir
sind Namen die schon dadurch das
Interesse und das sind alle vier
berufstätig
nur so geht das
nur einer ist immer da
ich bin relativ klar doch durch meinen
Job also wenn ich Weg bin nicht ganz Weg
auf Tour
aber ich da bin ich immer tagsüber da
und ob das ein Kind oder 2 1 Petric
SYSCOM egal
Unzen die anderen arbeiten auch zum Teil
intimen Schicht berufen
die Bauma
der Druckereien und ist ein Teil kann
oder was auch immer
meine Rolle ist auch im Theater wir
können es ganz gut dass mitteilen
und so Klein sind die Kinder auch nicht
mehr
wie klingt es ganz gut hin oder sie
billiger das ist Prozent und wird man
auch genug Platz
da sie Daten zu machen also wirklich
jeder
und dann dann geht das
also dienen WG Stress können
also es gibt keinen ärger darum der
Kopf des Club of the Road erwirken um
die Sache nehmen
in München
anamorph zwei Bäder
weil er eine Küche Jak trotzdem wenn
wir eine Krise hat
wenn es eine Passagen diese hat dann
hofft man bei Amazon Android und
bekannten Gutachten das
ist es vielleicht sogar im Vorteil
wir müssen unsere Leute haben so viel
gegenseitig einem neuen Krisenherd jeder
menschenleer
zweimal in einer Live Liebesbeziehungen
sollte es doch so ein bisschen aus zu
sein dass man
dann Partnern und Partnerinnen Krise hat
und dann fängt man es leicht auf rund
40 50
es ist für uns auch so Assist ist genug
Platz da sie sich aus dem Weg gehen kann
und es gibt genug Alltag besser
bewältigen
jetzt kommt und natürlich macht man
doch mal was die Kreuz und quer
dazu sucht Rat findet Rat unterhält
auch einfach mal die Klappe
aber das schöne in Szene wir brauchen
fassten die Missetaten zwar auch für
die Abende Norbert Born Decke auf den
Kopf
das ist ein Bier trinken gehen
und falls ein paar und nicht immer
alleine als typische einer geht der
andere Asolo muss
Wochen vorher schon einen Babysitter
wenn man nur mal irgendwie ein Bier
trinken gehen will dass
es ist hilft sehr viel bei der
Organisation und das so ist
wie die erste tolle Form
und Prozent
wir geben uns nicht auf» hieß
sachkundig glaube man kann auch es gibt
auch andere Leute mit den Mann
die einen nicht Nerven
das kommt auf einen Versuch drauf an
ich glaube das Scheitern mehr eben als
Wohngemeinschaft ein Sprecher ich hab
keine Ahnung
FNP Oktober es ist einfacher da bleibt
man länger zu sein
es wird es auch wieder einen zu Hause
pmz ganze Dreck
das ist doch probieren
bei uns Gates und
da kann dann ja auch
und wie ist deine Eltern vorgelebt
Proteste
umsichtige sagt keine Mama ich kein Papa
sondern sie erwiesen sich das Leben
Eduard Erdmann hatte sich weiter sehr
von Laschet
auf wer das sagen alle immer diese
achten dass der CAS in Lausanne nicht
einmal
Na klar dass wohl doch alle glauben und
es ist auch schön und wir sind auch
keine Biografie Sachen Leiharbeit so war
Schartel Idee ist wirklich traurig also
ein Kind das auf wagt aufwächst und
seine Eltern prinzipiell schon man nicht
versteht weil sie die Elektra eben Haiti
für den Proben nehmen und die
klassischen Achtundsechziger Hitliste
das öffentliche jetzt das muss
eigentlich jedem klar sein
kein Wunder dass die Leute das wirklich
eins zu eins genommen wobei das mit Mama
und Papa und mir hat es gibt ja auch
erstmalig auf der lebt im Meer
man hätte damit es nicht unbeliebt
also ich mach dass er deutlich anders
als meine Eltern
hab mir da aber auch Meso also will in
so lebens- Sachen gar nicht soviel
Vorbilder gegönnt sondern sehr viel
gehören neben Berggruen
das ist so
so sensitiv glaube ich kann man schon
sein
dass man sagt tut mir gut tut mir nicht
gut
es gibt ja und da lachten sich die an
ich weiß nicht ob es bei deinen Eltern
der Fall ist es gibt ja wann
also nicht viele
Rechthaberei
die haben ja recht einfach Japan liegt
aber da bin ich ja ich hab eigentlich
sei das direkt in die Kamera einen
gesunden ein sehr gesundes Misstrauen
gegenüber
Autoritäten
was sollte man sich bewahren egal ob es
Eltern Lehrer
regierende
oder
ob ich mich ja und Nein ab doch
gegenüber dem Dauerregen über
Vorbilder Netz genommen sehr kritisch
und so
ein mich übelst Rehm
0 gegen den TuS Xanten
also dagegen geben ist gar kein so
falsches
die haben mich immer recht
die tun auftauchten
die kochende Millionen Mitgliedern
Peter Lehmann am Ende auch schon
deutlich dass vor sie habe damit ich
eher sagen genauso nicht das glaube ich
nicht aber diese immer noch verheiratet
so überlebte Eltern wer diesen noch
verheiratet aber trotzdem glaube ich
dass erstmal sinnvoll
prinzipiell
gegen Eltern aufzubegehren
egal wie sie drauf sind
also das ist glaube ich ganz normal und
das war bei mir auch ausgeprägt
und nicht nur künstlerisch in denen ich
Dieter Prozent
niedergeschrieben habe im sehr sehr
verfremdeter Form kommen
also ich will bei Leibe
das zunächst zu machen wenn meine
Eltern
aber oft auch ganz tolle Sachen das Kind
ja jeder
aber wenn ich mich so an wie meine
Mutter Pam ist alles zu spät dann muss
ich euch mal um Block laufen dann ist
alles schiefgelaufen
gut elf Prozent auch bei festhalten der
Schweinegrippe
und Prozent erreichen
viel Erfolg und wenig Zuschauer
das tun sie nicht gehen das ist alles
ganz gut ich bedanke mich
Super vielen dank